Speaker 1: You know, last week,
or maybe it was the week before
I told you about a report that looked at how
COVID denialism and COVID conspiracy delusions
have been a great feeder into anti-Semitic
conspiracy theories and all of the different
overlaps that exist about shadow government
both being controlled by Jews and wanting
everybody injected with tracking devices or, you
know, whatever the case may be. The point is,
this report found how online COVID denialism and
COVID conspiracies are very much interlaced with
antisemitic conspiracy theories and white
supremacy, white nationalism, etc. Now,
anytime there's a report, it can be sort of
abstract and we might not see or understand
in practice the way that this comes together. I
have an example for you that was sent to me by
a few viewers today. We're going to be looking at
video here of from a few days ago. I believe this
was Wednesday or Thursday of last week. This
is the Chandler Governing Board study session
and regular business meeting. And there is a woman
who is going to speak and you're going to listen
to her momentarily. And it is really the perfect
storm. It's an amalgam of anti-vax anti-mask
anti critical race theory, delusions, ignorance,
shadow government conspiracy ism. And of course,
she ties it all together in a nice little bow and
says, It's all the Jews, folks. It's really all
the Jews. So one race is responsible. The Jews are
making the vaccines. The Jews control the shadow
government, the Jews control the pharmaceutical
companies. And this is what we're talking about
when we say these are the ways that these things
come together. It may be one of the most insane
clips I've seen since this all started. Let's
jump right into it. Warning, you know, if you
don't want kids to see this, I would understand
getting them out of the room. Let's listen.
Speaker 3: My name is Melanie Rattler. I'm a
veterinarian. I was a former teacher in Phenix
Senior High School District. I'm a cloning
expert with 35 years experience. And I was a
consultant to the CDC and on the pharmacy.
Speaker 1: So do we know if any of those
things are true? She was of that. She was
a teacher. She's an expert on cloning.
She was a consultant to the CDC, presumably. I
don't know on something related to veterinary
stuff. And she owned a pharmacy. Did she own
a human pharmacy or a veterinary pharmacy?
We don't know if any of it's true.
Speaker 3: I want to tell you that
this vaccine, this COVID vaccine, is a deadly
poison. I'm just going to tell you that everybody
that takes it is damaging their immune system, and
they're talking about this in given to children
now. It's going to destroy them.
Speaker 1: Now,
it's already been tested on tens of thousands of
kids in clinical trials, and the kids are fine
Speaker 3: to do more research
on it. I'm an expert on it and
I'm telling you that's what it's doing.
Speaker 1: What's also interesting is that
all of the expertize she claims to have, which
includes being a veterinarian consultant to
the CDC, pharmacy owner, teacher expert on
cloning. None of that relates to vaccines.
You would imagine that she would have mentioned
in that litany of expertize that she's also an
expert on vaccines, but she didn't.
Speaker 3: All right. The next thing
is the next topic is the CRT. I agree with
what both of these people said. But you know
what? If you want to talk about racism, you
want to bring it in and let's bring it in.
Let's get to the bottom of the bottom of it.
You talk about white supremacy. OK, let's get to
the very bottom of it. Every one of these things
the deep state, the cabal, the swamp, the elite,
you can't mention it, but I will. There is one
race that owns all the pharmaceutical companies,
and these vaccines aren't safe. They are effective
and they are free. You know that you're paying
for it through the increase in gas prices, the
increase in food prices. You're paying for this
and it's being taken from your money and given to
these pharmaceutical companies. And if you want
to bring race into this, it's the juice.
Speaker 1: Well, you are. Have you ever
so a smattering of applause there as she ties
together all of these different things inflation,
gas prices, critical race theory, the vaccines
through the pharmaceutical companies, the shadow
government, it's all the Jews, according to
this woman. This is the prototypical example
of how this stuff works, and it just works
so well for them. It feels so cohesive and
and coherent and logical. This is this is what
we were talking about last week with the report
about how this this COVID stuff feeds
right into the anti-Semitism. And again,
you know, the the framing of you're
not allowed to say it, but I'm going to
use the same group is in control of all
this stuff, the shadow government and the
gas prices. The I guess the I guess the Jews
on the gas stations is what she's saying. And
the various products may be the most insane
clip I've seen since all of this started.